اخويا
حلم خرصاص مبكرا جاءت صرخه الفنان السوري
سميح شقير لتواجه روايه السلطه عما يجري
في درعا
[موسيقى]
معلنه ميلاد فن لا يدور في فلك السلطان
وهي اول مره تحت حكم نظام الاسد تاججت نار
الثوره واحتدم الصراع وظل المنشدون
يترجمون راي الشارع بشكل واضح
بعد ان ساد الصمت لعقود
[موسيقى]
ومن الثوره السوريه كان نظام يواجهنا
برصاص كده احنا
عباره دليل على السلميتنا
الفنان سمير الاكتع يحرص على لقاء
المتظاهرين في احتفالات ذكرى الثوره لهذا
العام وهو يواصل انتاج اغاني تواكبها
الله اكبر سوريا لغير الرب ما بتنحني
[تصفيق]
مستواها صار اعلى الشباب عم تستقبل
هالاغاني بطريقه كتير حلوه عم ترفع
المعنويات
عم ترجع روح الثوره عم نتذكر حتى بالكلمات
عم نتذكر الشام والشام ان شاء الله راح
ترجع لنا
لم يمتلك الثوار السلاح في بدايه الثوره
فاعتمدوا الفن اسلوب مقاومه
يوحد بين الناس ويمنحهم الامل من خلال
الاغاني التي وصفت بالصدق والعفويه لذلك
ظلت خالده ترددها الاجيال التي لم تعاصر
انطلاقه الثوره السوريه
لم يخفت هنا صوت اناشيد ثوره السوريه رغم
الدمار وتعقيدات المشهد ودخول الدول
الاقليميه ساحه الصراع الطويل وامام معاشه
السوريون يقول المتظاهرون ان هذا الصوت
يمثل لهم صوت الحريه الذي لن يتراجعوا عنه
صهيب الخلف الجزيره ريفو ادلب